I think Samiha already showed these
these are the buoys we have now come on
here is another implementation we made
it gives you the opportunity to run a
batch that was also done in Mathematica
so you essentially here is workable it's
point2 you said okay so we have here one
right here for to load data were to
write the output then big it's a CSV
format so it's a simple plain text
format organized as a table you load it
and then you can run all patients and
one run and here this table gives you
then all the patients you calculated
giving you information on the left side
on the measurement and then on the right
side what lens is the best one so that
you can see what to choose here we have
chosen only one lens you can get five
results 10 or dollars whatever is
necessary but typically you a surgeon is
used to a small number of lenses he's
always using so it doesn't make sense to
generate a huge list of results this
samee already showed now come on
what we what I hear did is we have now a
c++ executable and I want to make
accessible as soon as possible for
example bench mode implementing this in
C++ is taking some time so what I do is
I use Mathematica to call several times
the c++ getting the output and then post
process and generating a table from that
so first I preprocess here some CSV data
these are the patients essentially
that's a simple table and then I run the
calculation here's an executable i
created the c++ executable i collect the
output post process and generate this
table in Mathematica so I get quick
results and light I can prototype like
this and later I can implement this in
C++ are after I've gone all these wrong
paths that I'm not satisfied with it's
much quicker in Mathematica ah and again
I can look as deep as I like the C++
executable generates a lot of
information it's not necessary to have
any details but to show you how many
results are generated so whenever you
need more you can have access to it and
playing with this in Mathematica is much
faster than in C++ you just play with it
look at it and then you decide what's
the best for user another issue is to
run what Samia said to check if the
formula C use the algorithms viewers are
correct or not I prefer to use identical
same C++ executable I later use it for
user if I use Mathematica to a copy
paste put it in C++ that can be always a
type or whatever well I prefer to use
exactly the C++ executable then I call
it in Mathematica I run through a whole
bunch of values and this for example is
looking nice but then this is now the
power calculated for the lens in depend
essentially of the curvature of the eye
and you think everything is fine but
then if you look at the dependence on
the length of the eye that's the next
graph you'll see oops there may be a
problem on the left side for very short
eyes on the right side for very long
eyes so like this you can see if you're
for algorithms you are using our good
another thing we use for example we have
formula to kick your light the power of
the lens but later you want after the
calculation know how much as the patient
is left with so how well you really
correct it so you must solve the inverse
problem typically you use some numerical
stuff to do it here for example was fine
truth but Mathematica can do better so
you can symbolically solve the equation
post-process a bit and then you get here
some thing you can paste a string
directly in the c++ executable no type
was because it's automatically processed
and one advantage is speed here it's
about 30 times faster then the fine
truth obviously because it's just a
simple formula to use no nothing no real
algorithm to find a solution but I think
we'll run bit out of time